[Music]
so Jeff Bezos says our recession is
coming and you should not spend money on
an automobile refrigerator or whatever
and listen I agree if you're going to
spend money on anything especially
during recession the thing to spend
money on is skills learn a skill that
you can then translate into money
because you're providing value to other
people with your newly acquired skill
set some of the best businesses of all
time have been created during our
session because you learn how to bring
value people who will win right now
during a reception of those who learn
how to bring value how to bring value
because you have an amazing skill set
that you invested in yourself for so
learn how to Market learn how to build
websites learn how to help people on
social media learn how to make amazing
videos learn a skill set that can
improve your work to the market so that
you can then sell that to other people
as a service ideally and start making
money invest in yourself learn skills
translate bad into money that's how you
win in this conversation